Both: Hee-hee-hoo, hee-hee-hoo.
The whole breathing
technique that she's doing,
with the "hee-hee-hoo,"
I've never actually
heard that in my career.
Hi, I am Dr. Ali Rodriguez.
I am an OB-GYN.
Today we're going to be looking
at pregnancy scenes in movies and in TV
and judging them for realism.
Nurse: That's it. The
doctor will be right in.
Jane: Thank you.
Rafael: Thank you.
You know, I think they did
do a good job in this one
in making the baby bump look real.
I think, I mean, it's believable.
I think she looks pregnant to me.
Let's check again in two weeks.
How big the belly gets.
When we do fundal height,
that's the measurement from the pubic bone
all the way to the top of the uterus.
The top of the uterus
is called the fundus,
which is why it's called fundal height.
That is something that's
typically not done standing up.
It would be very uncomfortable
and very difficult to do,
because the more, you know,
obviously the bigger you get in pregnancy,
it's going to be harder to get down
to that pubic bone accurately
from the squatting
position that she's doing.
Instead of the belly
growing, like, outward,
we'd expect it to grow almost up,
because the uterus and
baby are growing up.
But currently the baby is breech.
Head is up here, tush is down here.
And the baby needs to be head
down for a natural delivery.
I think the doctor does do a good job
of explaining what that means
and almost not to worry at this point.
Throughout pregnancies,
babies will turn from breech to cephalic,
and they'll kind of do flips
and twirl around in there, and that's OK.
Typically by the point that, you know,
a patient is 33 weeks,
that's when we really
want baby to kind of start
moving towards head down,
because, like she mentions
at the end of the clip,
the bigger baby gets and the
closer you are to full term,
they start running out of room.
So if they haven't flipped by then,
it's unlikely for them
to flip on their own,
just because they just don't
have the space anymore.
It looks very real.
She looks pregnant to me, and
I think they did a good job.
So, yeah, I'd say 7 out of 10.
Get out! Oh, no.
[screams]
Certainly birth can be traumatic.
You know, a patient comes
in completely dilated
or, you know, having really
bad contractions at home.
That's when it can get a little traumatic,
but usually it's really not traumatic.
Obviously it makes it more entertaining
and funny to have it be this way.
Push! One, two, three.
I always tell all of
my patients, you know,
pushing and going through
labor is a lot of work,
and you are going to
be pushing pretty hard.
In order for it to be, I guess, effective,
it's not necessarily
how hard you're pushing,
but are you using the right muscles?
So, as funny as it sounds,
the same muscles we use
to go to the bathroom
are the same muscles we
use to push out a baby.
[screams]
Good!
Usually when we see clips in movies,
you always have that blue sheet
kind of draped over the legs.
And, honestly, that's rarely ever used.
I don't think I've ever used
it in any of the deliveries.
The patient always has a
hospital gown on, definitely.
Oh, that's a pretty big baby.
I'd say the average size or weight
of a newborn is anywhere
between 6 to 7 pounds,
and they're usually about,
like, 19 to 20 inches long.
This baby to me appears to
be much bigger than that.
I don't think they're actually using
a newborn for these scenes.
They definitely show,
like, this clean baby,
and here it looks like they've
done a little bit of makeup.
But typically babies are born
with something called vernix,
but this vernix, it almost serves
as a protective covering over fetus' skin
when they're in utero.
It almost looks like a
really white, thick lotion.
And I think that's what
they tried to kind of
put the makeup on the baby.
As you can see, there's
white little chunks.
Think of it as like a baby lotion.
So it's OK to kind of
rub it into their skin.
But I am gonna give it to them.
I think they did a good job
of trying to put the makeup on the baby.
I'd give it a 5 out of 10.
One of the first presenting
symptoms of early pregnancy
can be nausea and vomiting.
A lot of my patients,
they'll cook a whole meal,
and then they sit down to eat it
and they just want to vomit.
You have that surge of
estrogen, progesterone,
human -- or I guess hCG,
which is a pregnancy hormone, increases,
and all of that, you know,
there's a heightened sense of smell
in women who are pregnant.
[ripping]
[Bella screaming]
Seeing this much blood is not concerning.
Seeing a vampire do the C-section
with his teeth is very
impressive and concerning.
But, yeah, typically childbirth
is a process that is very bloody.
We obviously don't want
them to lose too much,
which is why we still monitor vitals.
And when you're closer to
that 40 weeks' gestation,
the uterus and the baby are getting
about 450 milliliters
of blood in a minute.
After delivery, you still
have all of that blood
that's pumping to the uterus.
So if there's some sort of, you know,
issue or something going on,
that's a lot of blood that
a patient's going to lose
in a matter of seconds.
Simply cannot handle this one,
this gets a 1 out of 10.
This is just too much, over the top,
and very unrealistic.
I just took the pregnancy test.
Just tell me when a minute's up.
I just put some pizza rolls
in the microwave oven.
The minute that bad boy
dings, we're good to go.
I think it'd be a good distraction from it
because, you know, it's sometimes a moment
that can be very nerve-wracking
and cause a lot of anxiety.
So I think distracting yourself
with something is a good idea.
By the way, next time, buy
a name-brand pregnancy test.
Not that cheap generic one.
Some of them are definitely advertised to
find out at the earliest
point in pregnancy.
And that just simply means those ones
may be a little bit more sensitive
to the level of pregnancy hormone.
Most of these pregnancy tests that you buy
at the store, supermarket, or pharmacy,
they're pushing, like,
99-percentile accuracy.
So they're usually pretty good.
Wait a second. Results in three minutes.
How long should you wait?
Each brand and everything
like that will vary.
Some of them are a minute.
Some of them, you know, three minutes.
Just really depends, but make sure
you read the packaging correctly
so that something like
this doesn't happen.
You know, I think they did a great job.
9 out of 10, everything
was pretty accurate.
I think it's fun and obviously hysterical
that he finds the box and is like,
"Oh, my goodness, three minutes."
I have to sneeze.
[sneezes]
[baby cries]
Wow. That's one baby out.
Actually, this is something
that is very possible.
I've had deliveries,
especially when it's someone
who's a multigravida,
which means she's had
multiple pregnancies.
The more pregnancies you have,
typically the faster the labor course is.
And so I've had women who, you know,
it's their fifth, sixth baby,
and they come in and, you know,
once the baby's there and crowning,
they just cough, and baby comes out.
If this were her first
pregnancy, probably not.
Your body's never done it before,
so it would be very difficult.
Push. Here we go.
Sometimes I find myself,
like, pushing almost for them,
because you just, you know,
you want to try and help.
What ends up happening a
lot of the times though
that I've seen, when the
partners are like this,
it bothers the patient sometimes.
And so they'll kind of be like, "Go away,"
or, you know, "Don't stand next to me!"
You pull out this bar,
and it connects to the
bottom, like around the table.
And so the purpose of that is instead of
you kind of laying on your back
with your legs up in stirrups,
this one kind of simulates
a position of squatting.
Doctor: We need to
prepare for a C-section.
No, no, no, no. No, I have a birth plan.
I want to push. I want to push.
She had this birth plan,
but it seems like an emergency's going on.
The baby's heart rate was dropping.
So at that point it would be
an indication for a C-section.
There is kind of this
saying on labor and delivery
that if you have this
rigid and set birth plan,
that it's going to end up in a C-section.
We're not saying it as a mean thing,
but I think it's important
that when you are pregnant
and going in to have a baby,
you have to go with a mindset of,
yes, this is the birth plan that you want,
but you have to be able
to be flexible to change,
because a lot of it is out of our control.
You know, in this scene,
where the baby's heart rate's dropping,
obviously no one wants to see that.
They did a pretty good job with
showing the different
scenarios that can take place.
9 out of 10. They did good.
Wanda: I can't do this.
Yes you can.
I can't.
When, you know, she's obviously looking up
and saying, "I can't do
this," and kind of panicking,
that is extremely accurate.
It's almost like they go
into this, like, panic mode.
I always like to tell them that,
yes, it is extremely
painful, this is temporary,
and they're going to feel so
much better once they deliver.
Both: Hee-hee-hoo, hee-hee-hoo.
The whole breathing
technique that she's doing,
with the "hee-hee-hoo,"
I've never actually
heard that in my career.
It's just good to take
good, big, deep breaths,
you know, in the nose,
out through the mouth,
kind of stay a little bit more calm.
Laying flat on their back on the floor,
I don't think this is realistic.
I don't find this position
to be comfortable.
Most women, whether
they're doing home births
or in the hospital, a lot of the times
they're still either squatting,
they can kind of be on
their back, but not flat,
almost just kind of propped up,
almost like you're doing, like, ab workout
and you're kind of doing
that crunch position.
I would say that's more comfortable
than just being flat on your back.
It's going to be very hard to breathe
and be very uncomfortable,
because that's a lot of weight
that's just kind of sitting on your chest.
[baby crying]
Babies actually do cry
as soon as they're born,
and we want them to cry.
When they're in utero,
their lungs aren't working, essentially.
So once they are born,
they're kind of squeezed on their way
out of the birth canal,
and they give that first cry.
It actually helps them
kind of expand everything
and make sure everything's functioning.
Sometimes they can swallow a little bit
of the amniotic fluid,
so by them kind of crying
and coughing it out,
it's actually really helpful.
That baby is spotless.
That baby is very, very clean immediately.
Again, not something
that is realistic at all.
So I'd have to say
either 1 or 2 out of 10.
Cravings in pregnancy, very, very common.
Especially in the first trimester,
it can start that early.
And then the cravings can kind of change
as the pregnancy progresses.
I have heard some very
interesting combinations of food.
A lot of pickle juice,
or pickles with, like,
chocolate, I've heard,
which does not sound good to me at all.
Go ahead and treat yourself.
But every now and then, yeah,
it's not going to hurt anything.
[Stan clears throat]
If you're craving a deli
sandwich or anything like that,
it's important that you make sure
that the meat is hot.
The big thing is avoiding any
sort of raw meat or raw fish.
Obviously she's overindulging,
but I think it's cute. It's funny.
So I'm gonna say 8 out of 10.
[heartbeat pumping]
That's the heartbeat.
140 beats a minute, perfectly normal.
When we're looking at fetal heart rate,
what's normal is anything between
110 beats per minute and
160 beats per minute.
So a fetus' heartbeat is
definitely much faster,
and that is completely normal and healthy.
Even in the first trimester,
that heartbeat can start pushing
180 and 190 beats per minute,
and that's OK.
The sonogram ultrasound
does look realistic.
Probably not his hand
movements on the actual belly,
but the actual picture does look good.
That little string of pearls.
That's the spine, yeah.
He said, "Oh, look, the string of pearls."
That is not something we typically use
to describe the spine.
Oddly enough, we do kind of describe it
as a railroad track,
because you can kind of see two, you know,
it looks just like a railroad track.
You gotta move back in with me.
I want you off your feet
as much as possible.
And no going to the lab.
This is actually a
recommendation that is outdated.
But before, doing bed rest
and having someone stay off of their feet
was kind of recommended all the time.
Then a lot of these patients
started developing blood clots
in their legs or in their lungs.
And so they did a lot of research on it,
and actually having someone
who's pregnant on bed rest
is, you know, increased
risk of blood clots.
The whole premise and plot of this movie,
of having Arnold Schwarzenegger
trying out this fertility drug
and then consequently ending up pregnant,
would be extremely unrealistic.
The ultrasound, I thought,
was very realistic,
but as something that, is
it going to be possible now?
Probably not.
So I would say probably
a 3 or 4 out of 10.
That's not enough.
What are you doing?!
I'm getting that baby out of you!
There's no real good data as to
any of these things that,
maybe they're old wives' tales
or things that you hear that
are gonna provoke labor.
Is it gonna hurt anything to try?
No, not really.
If you feel comfortable
and you find a comfortable
position for you
and you want to try and
have sex to see, why not?
The cervix in pregnancy,
which is the bottom part of the uterus,
tends to be pretty sensitive in pregnancy.
So anything that's going
to touch the cervix
or anything like that,
that can start cramping and contractions.
Oh, no, no.
I think my water just broke.
The majority of women,
their water doesn't break spontaneously
like we see in the movies.
This one's not quite as dramatic.
Most women, you know, contractions start,
and their water just doesn't break.
It'll break once they're in the hospital.
Ross: OK, I got the pillow.
Got the bag. You got the keys?
Rachel: I got the keys.
I don't think there's any
sense for you to panic
and, you know, rush and things like that.
But you certainly have time
to carefully grab your bags
and, you know, be rational
with your decisions,
get to the hospital safely.
I think they do a really good job,
and let's say ...
7, 6 out of 10?
This is your folic acid,
and this is your prenatal vitamin.
You're serious about this?
Definitely, this is the
most ridiculous size
prenatal vitamin I have ever seen.
If you have them that are this big,
please buy yourself another brand,
because this is just too much.
They're typically just, you know,
a regular vitamin, pill size.
They even come in a gummy formation now,
which has all the same nutrients.
It's actually encouraged and recommended
to start taking a prenatal vitamin,
I mean, really for all women
who are of reproductive age.
Even if you're not planning
on becoming pregnant,
it actually helps the
development of a fetus.
I can't do it.
I got it. It's going -- no.
It is really funny,
but seeing a prenatal
vitamin that's that big,
not a thing. Or it shouldn't be a thing.
So I would say 4 out of 10.